Good Morning John, it’s Friday...for the
last couple weeks, I’ve been thinking a
lot about boundaries.
The boundary between public and private.
The borders between nations.
The thresholds of our lives.
And the faultlines of ideology.
Interviewing President Obama was something
I could never regret, but being thrown into
the public eye has resulted in some people
saying nasty things about me, which I’m
actually not that used to.
So I’ve been trying to look at it all from
outside of my own experience.
My graduate degree is in environmental science,
so I often see my experiences through the
lens of ecology.
Boundaries are exceptional places ecologically.
The area where two biomes blend is called
an ecotone and they tend to be more diverse
and biologically productive than either biome
alone.
Many species specialize in survival on that
edge where access to both biomes increases
the available resources
The edge, in other words, is a fantastic place.
But it’s also a violent place.
Predators have access to more prey, and prey
have to watch for more predators.
That tension is, in nature, what drives increases
in productivity and diversity.
The edge between the land and the sea has
always been and remains a source of great
biological productivity, but it has also given
rise to great cultural and economic productivity.
The edge effect, it seems, exists outside
of ecology as well.
There are personal edges, whether it’s the
finite moment a person becomes a parent.
Or a more drawn out transition, like that
of child to adult.
Difficult times, sure, but full of deeply
valuable personal growth.
Just as ecological boundaries are massively
productive, tumultuous, and wonderful, so
are boundaries between cultures.
And in the last week I’ve tried to see the
political debate in this country that way.
I’ve tried to imagine that the boundary
between ideologies is a productive yet tumultuous
place, and occasionally it is.
But the benefits from the boundary come not
from a harsh, edge.
Where the ocean meets a wall, the ecosystem
does not become more productive.
The most productive ectones are those stretched
out over miles.
The ocean eating the land, the land eating
the ocean in a never-ending burbling that
gives rise to beautiful but impenetrable wetlands.
Instead of reaping the benefits of a gradient
between ideologies, I see people intentionally
poisoning it in order to protect their perceived
righteousness.
Eventually, you have what ecologists call
a monoculture...one plant as far as the eye
can see.
A desert of diversity that may be productive,
but is extremely unstable.
Any outside influence can crash the entire
system.
I do not want to live in a world of ideological
monocultures and I do not think that I do.
But pretending like we do is in the best interests
of a few people who happen to have a lot of
power.
So I do not propose dismantling the boundary...I
propose celebrating it.
Ideological diversity is not a sign of a divided
nation, it’s a sign of a thoughtful nation.
And I’ve found the best way to really believe
this is just to simply stop listening to the
people telling us to hate each other.
As wrong as you might think others are, you
are never always going to be right.
Everyone will be stronger if viewpoints are
allowed to mix into a diversity of ideas,
and strategies.
The ecological success of the edge comes from
this mixing, and I think it’s an important
part of the success of democracy as well.
Yes, one side is going to feel safer to you,
it’s going to make more sense to you, but
to reach our full potential, we need the merge
that divide into a biome all its own, more
fertile, more diverse, and more productive
than we could ever be alone.
John, I’ll see you on Tuesday